foreign
system doesn't appreciate such as people
in abusive households who couldn't get
out of it because their husband was the
only one who had ever had a job are
people who were off of welfare or
government Aid and they couldn't
actually get off of it because again no
credit there's very serious gaps that
people wanted us to solve for them and
by talking to our members we learned
that very quickly
[Music]
Ultra is a financial app that helps
people build credit using their
subscriptions imagine your Netflix Hulu
Spotify and others helping you build
your credit history we serve and aim to
serve people who've never been exposed
to the credit system before a community
that's been unseen and not really
appreciated by the current American
systems
I started my company out of a personal
frustration honestly I was the first one
in my family to actually go to college
out of a nine person household and
didn't realize that tuition was
something that you actually had to pay
for I was ten thousand dollars short on
my tuition and actually didn't know what
to do my family didn't have the funds I
didn't have the funds and unfortunately
I got denied from every loan company out
there simply because I had never been
exposed to the credit system only got in
because I called the university every
day so they paid for my tuition but it
did teach me that not only myself off
but millions of others struggle with the
zero to one gap of credit access
[Music]
to date we've raised about 22 million
dollars in capital which is awesome to
say as a first time founder I I believe
the experience has been
life-changing and good and bad ways
about a year ago a year and a half we
were in a hacker house so it's 12 people
in a three bedroom apartment trying to
figure out this world of bureaucracy and
fintech and overnight our app literally
went viral
you're known as the Jay-Z company
because Marcy Ventures was our first
investors we had just raised our seed
round and I think in the span of 60 days
we had over 300 000 downloads more than
12 people in The Hacker House could
understand we quickly jumped into our
series a raised more money use that
Capital to really embrace the members
who were joining us and continue to
write that momentum
[Music]
early on I realized that there was bad
VCS there was VCS that were in it just
to take money hostile takeovers people
who didn't believe in me and the mission
that we wanted to serve VCS who wanted
to change our agenda to become a payday
loan provider to give out 200 APR loans
to do all the stuff that we're fighting
against so although I'm very glad we've
raised 22 million dollars the 22 million
is stemmed from positive socially driven
investors people like pendulum who are
focused on creating generational wealth
for black and brown communities and a
number of our celebrity investors as
well who've cared about the mission more
than the returns
foreign
I think my legacy is
something greater than myself what we've
built and what I've dedicated my life to
is truly changing the lives of others
and I don't say that in the Facebook
type of way but truly I I think that my
life has been dedicated and I've had the
opportunity to be impactful to others
lives and the stories I've heard on the
people who have trusted us and myself to
be that Catalyst in their life has been
bigger than I could have ever imagined
and I embraced that and I take that
every day
everyone who we employ everyone that
we're building with they know that we're
building something greater than
ourselves and startup number two three
four five will all be down that same
mission
[Music]